monsieur enfin mon général comment
expliquer que monsieur alain gibelin ait
omis de parler du déjeuner du 25 avril
que vous avez eue avec monsieur gibelin
vous monsieur gibelin et monsieur
benalla pendant lequel monsieur gibelin
et monsieur benalla ont discuté des des
équipements qui seraient livrés à
monsieur benalla pour le 1er mai est ce
vrai mon général
mais il semble que là nous ayons
quelques quelques divergences ou en tout
cas des points 2-2 de contradictions
mémorial si je puis dire oui et des
effets tuning et des noirs qui flanche
si bien si j'ai bien compris
écoutez je ne peux pas dire autre chose
que ce que j'ai déjà dit à l'ats
auditions de la commission de
l'assemblée nationale
ce repas pour moi n'avaient pas un
caractère
d'exception donc je n'en ai pas retenu
l'ensemble des détails
la seule chose qui manque mais qui m'est
revenu c'est qu'il a été évoqué lors de
ce repas la manifestation du 1er mai
bien sûr et pourquoi monsieur gibelin
dit que ce serait pas n'a pas existé
mais il a omis de lui qui n'a pas dit
qu'il n'a pas existé
il a omis de le signaler un problème
ce repas bien eu les mêmes il est même
on doit pouvoir retracer quelques par la
danse de la présidence de république
mais ce repas a bien eu lieu
je pense pas qu'un régime lundi que
repas n'avait pas eu lieu je veux vous
remercier
prenons bonne note de votre réponse je
vais mais non madame madame benbassa il
faut que tous les collègues puissent
s'exprimer mais je vous remercie de
votre question